yearly ye le we have a foundation and
the website y le y le org it's a
foundation I started a few years ago and
we started it because we wanted to bring
self-esteem back to Haiti and currently
seven thousand kids have scholarships we
started something which is called hip
hop on Sunday hip hop for health mobile
clinics going throughout Haiti giving
people HIV test giving them condoms but
through music there's also a children
prison program where we went into these
prisons where there's kids introduced
chest took over the prison's put more
beds basketball courts and these kids
are reading and every time I go down
there tears come to my eyes because I
knew I was in the beginning a lot of
these kids was in gangs most terrible
violence you can think about and yearly
is actually the movement is really
working and it's it's the greatest thing
is when I look at a kid and I noticed
that I can rise his self-esteem because
someone rose my self-esteem that's why
I'm here that's healing
well the first thing is we have a
documentary coming out which is called
cry Haiti and this is my work on the
ground for the past three years I didn't
leave the ground until I felt that the
people on the ground understood what we
was doing and was training so I kept
going back and forth back and forth and
now I feel like we have great a great
team on the ground we have a great NGOs
but to get it it took three years of me
going back and forth to Haiti a lot of
times when you start the foundations for
it to really work you have to be
hands-on for the first couple of years
and and right now it's a natural will
it's moving